good evening we have just finished a
meeting of the NATO Ukraine commission
with the foreign minister
dimitro colaba
this was also our first meeting with
Finland as a full NATO member
we addressed Russia's brutal war of
aggression our support for Ukraine and
its euro-atlantic aspirations
the people of Ukraine continue to defend
the country with skill and bravery
and we will continue to support him for
as long as it takes
NATO allies have delivered close to 150
billion euros of support including 65
billion euros of military aid
but there is no room for complacency
President Putin has not changed course
in Ukraine
Outlaws our support
our meeting today underscored NATO's
enduring commitment to Ukraine allies
are ramping up on the production of
weapons and ammunition and delivering on
their pledges of training a new heavy
weaponry
the first level part uh and Challenger
tanks are in Ukraine
together with tanks and infantry
fighting vehicles from several other
allies
as agreed at the Madrid Summit we have
also stepped up urgent non-lethal
support to NATO's Ukraine fund
this includes fuel medical supplies
mobile satellite systems and Pantone
Bridges
I thank allies that have made
substantial contributions such as
Germany
the Netherlands Norway and the United
Kingdom and partners such as Australia
and Japan
a welcome that ministers have made more
announcements today and I expect more in
the coming days and months
building on this we will develop a
multi-year support Initiative for
Ukraine to help ensure Ukraine's returns
and defense make the transition from
Soviet era equipment and doctrines to
Nato standards and increase
interoperability with NATO
this demonstrates our long-term
commitment to Ukraine and brings Ukraine
closer to the euro Atlantic family
allies made clear that we remain
committed to NATO's open door policy we
encourage Ukraine to continue on the
path of reforms even in difficult times
we discussed the importance of
anti-corruption measures the rule of law
and the rights of minorities
a strong independent Ukraine is vital
for the stability
of the euro-atlantic area and we look
forward to meeting President zelensky at
our village Summit in July
NATO will stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes Ukraine's future is in the
euro-atlantic family and with that I'm
ready to take your questions
okay Bloomberg
from Bloomberg how much have allies
contributed to the fund for Ukraine's
cap and how much are you seeking and why
is this so important thank you
well as allies are now stepping up so uh
I think uh we had to wait and see how
big announcements they will make in
total but I'm quite optimistic that
allies now realize the importance of
providing support uh also through the
NATO assistance fund and also to have
long-term commitments so by the windows
Summit I think we will have a
substantial amount of money and also a
commitment to a support for uh many
years a multi-air program so I think
I'll be careful going into this specific
announcement I think some allies
actually will uh tell you what they have
announced in the meeting but I will
leave it to them to to announce the
numbers they have announced in the
meetings today
Secretary General Lauren from Finland
could you please describe what is the
secret of Article 5 why can the Finns
now on trust that if someone attacks on
Finland Allied troops will come and help
Finland and then
how Finland can provide more concrete
security to Nato and make
Article 5 even better thank you very
much
NATO's core task is to prevent war is to
preserve peace is to prevent conflict
and the way we do that is to make it
absolutely clear that if any Allah is
attacked the whole Alliance will come
and assist and support because we regard
an attack on Allah as the attack on all
allies
based on the principle one for all all
for one and this has a preserved peace
preventive conflict
throughout decades for NATO allies and
we will continue to do so by standing
together because as long as any
potential adversary knows that the whole
Alliance will react that an attack on
one will be regardless and attack on all
then there will be no military attack on
a NATO allies and of course when Finland
now is a full member of a NATO then you
are covered by this guarantee which is a
way to preserve peace to prevent the
conflict to prevent armed attacks
Finland will contribute substantially to
this
because Finland has a substantial Armed
Forces high-end capabilities including
now more than 60 F-35 fighter jets air
defense systems and highly trained uh
well-equipped
troops and also air and enabled forces
so so so this combined with your second
and
non-experienced knowledge expertise on
resilience strong Democratic
institutions and of course also the fact
that they have a capable defense
industry all of that contributes to the
strength of NATO and let me add that if
you look at the map we also realize that
just the fact that Finland is located
where it is it's extremely important for
the high North for the Nordic countries
and for the Baltic countries in addition
to Nato as a whole
Ukraine
Ukraine which is currently a different
itself and all Europe in a bloody war
against Russian aggression aggressor
expects that NATO will extend uh an
invitation for Ukraine to join the
alliance at the July Summit in Vilnius
at what stage is this discussion within
the alliance and I have the second
question Secretary General Donato
countries plan to increase the supply of
ammunition to Ukraine and needs and when
NATO allies and partners are increasing
the supply of ammunition to to Ukraine
we have done that actually for several
weeks and months because uh uh not least
to the U.S led uh contact group uh for
Ukraine we are in close consultations
with Ukraine constantly and Ukraine
share with us their needs and it has
been obvious a long time that this has
now overcome a war or attrition which is
a battle of logistics meaning that
there's a constant need for more
ammunition more supplies
more enablers for the different
capabilities that Ukraine has and
therefore it has been a a big focus on
the need to step up not only the supply
or ammunition to Ukraine but also the
production we have worked with the
industry we are in close contact with
the European Union uh uh we are revising
the NATO guidelines for uh a battle
decisive ammunitions uh to ensure that
allies uh can replenish the stocks
because so far most of the ammunition
that has been delivered to Ukraine has
come from uh reducing our own stocks in
the long run that doesn't work so now
we're also ramping up the production to
replenish our own stocks and to continue
to provide ammunition to uh to Ukraine
and of course for Ukraine to launch
offensive operations to uh to to to to
continue to retake territory land to to
liberate more of the occupied land than
of course Ukraine needs a significant
amounts of ammunition for their
artillery systems for the battle tanks
for the elephant systems and for all the
different weapon systems that allies
have provided so this is this was an
issue discussed today it's an ongoing
dialogue with with Ukraine and then
NATO's position on membership is a
changed Ukraine will become a member of
the alliance that this has been stated
again again at NATO Summits at the same
time we all realize that
for to make any meaningful progress on
this issue the first step is to ensure
that Ukraine prevails as a sovereign in
the plant nation and that's the reason
why NATO allies and partners are
providing unprecedented level of support
and will continue to continue to do so
and why we are also in constant close
contact with the ukrainians and also
providing chaining and allies made those
announcements today about
additional support to Ukraine to ensure
that Ukraine prevails as a Soviet
independent state which is a
precondition for any meaningful
discussion about future membership
Swedish radio gentleman then
I saw you first how many working hours
Secretary General have you put in these
talks between Sweden Finland and turkey
so far and the second question uh what's
the next step what kind of a
breakthrough are you hoping for in the
talks between Sweden and turkey and
Hungaria as well so Sweden can be a
member of NATO in real news it seems
that you have a sort of a deadlock in
these talks right now
thank you well first of all I don't
count uh working hours in that way but
uh but uh but I welcome the fact that um
uh many allies and uh and and and uh
also uh people in many capitals have
been working hard to ensure that we are
making progress and also that we deliver
on what we all uh promised in Madrid uh
because we have to remember that all
allies made the decision uh in June last
year in Madrid to invite Finland and
Sweden and uh
as I have told you before this is the
fastest accession process in NATO's
modern history it's still not a year
since uh Sweden and Finland applied
normally these processes takes years and
we are already feeling as a full member
and 28 allies have ratified
Sweden as as a member and in the
meantime a lot of has happened so is
much closer and much more integrated
into NATO's civilian military structures
now than they were before they applied
and with Finland as a member that
further enhances Sweden's security
then there is no deadlock there was a
deadlock but we were able to lift that
deadlock because for some weeks or
months there were no meetings no contact
in the permanent mechanism
after meeting I had with President
adironda actually some weeks ago we
agreed to re-start that process we had a
meeting here at uh at the NATO
headquarters with Finland Sweden and uh
and turkey uh we agreed to meet again
and there are constant consultations I
spoke with President recently and we are
continuing to work at the different
levels to make progress also on the
accession of uh of Sweden so
Sweden will become a member we are
working hard to ensure that that happens
as soon as possible but it is important
to remember that Sweden is not left
alone it's not as if no one cares about
Sweden all allies cares about Sweden
allies are actually provided a bilateral
security assurances to Sweden allies
have increased their presence in the
region and Sweden is at the table the
Sweden is participating more and more in
in our military and and civilian
structures and it is inconceivable that
will be any attack or military threat
against Sweden without NATO reacting and
that's even more so with Finland inside
so
Sweden is in a much better place now
than before they applied and we will
ensure that also our full member as soon
as possible thank you very much I'm
afraid that's all we have time for we'll
see you tomorrow thank you see you
tomorrow thank you so much